bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre dans un
instant les débats des sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle à propos de la proposition
de loi classe leonetti créant de
nouveaux droits en faveur des malades et
des personnes en fin de vie
on en parle avec le président de la
commission des affaires sociales le
sénateur républicain du vaucluse
alain milon bonjour alors les sénateurs
notamment en commissions ont modifié le
texte pour lui apporter plus de sécurité
juridique notamment quels sont pour vous
les principaux apports du sénat cet
égard avant de répondre à votre question
si vous me permettez je voudrais juste
dire que l'apport essentiel de cette
proposition de loi claisse leonetti
c'est d'avoir mis en lumière le fait que
la loi leonetti en tant que telle était
suffisante mais qu'elle n'était pas
suffisamment connus da par des
professionnels en particulier n'est pas
suffisamment mise en application en
particulier en ce qui concerne les soins
palliatifs est donc cette cette avancée
considérable du constat qu'il manque de
soins palliatifs
les rapporteurs du sénat jean dorion et
michel amiel l'ont repris pour accentuer
la demande expresse de faire en sorte
que dans tous les services des hôpitaux
de france dans les ehpad et même à
domicile les soins palliatifs soit
considérée comme étant un élément
important de la médecine un élément
important de la fin de vie le deuxième
point qui est important dans ce qui a
été mis en place par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat
c'est le fait que la sédation profonde
pourra être mise en place mais qu'il
faudra qu'elle soit encadrée et qu'il
faudra surtout que la haute autorité
santé détermine quels sont les seront
les principes qui devront être mis en
place principe médicamenteux qui devront
être mis en place pour que cette
cessation profondes soient mises en
application
mais qu'elles soient mises en
application dans dans des termes qui
soient des termes légaux et qu'il n'y
ait pas par la suite
dépassement de prises d'habitude vous
n'avez pas vers le suicide assisté
ouvert l'euthanasie sans le dire surtout
vers l'euthanasie sans le dire ce qui
nous semble être pour nous tout au moins
une chose que nous ne voulons pas mais
justement les partisans de l'euthanasie
et du suicide assisté ici notamment les
écologistes estiment qu'on ne va pas
assez loin il part notamment des
différentes propositions de loi qu'ils
avaient été déposés au sénat depuis 2008
il y en a eu sept qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je suis pas favorable l'euthanasie
je ne suis pas favorable au suicide
assisté
et quand on regarde bien les sondages
c'est vrai que si on demande à une
personne en bonne santé de 30 ans est ce
que quand vous serez en fin de vie
malades avec des souffrances vous voulez
qu'on vous permettre d'avoir un accès à
la mort plus facile tout le monde répond
oui par contre lorsque vous avez 80 ans
que vous êtes en fin de vie mais les
derniers instants vous avez envie de les
vivre
vous avez envie de vivre avec les
personnes qui vous entourent vous avez
envie de les vivre parce que vous avez
besoin communiquer sur le constat de
votre vie sur l'amour que vous portez
aux gens qui sont autour de vous sur la
façon dont vous avez vécu il ya ce
besoin là qui existe et qu'il faut
respecter
je vais dire dans mon discours tout à
l'heure que jusqu'à jusqu'au terme de la
vie la vie existe et qu'il faut la
respecter
vous le disiez le les soins palliatifs
qui doivent être développés c'est un
sujet qui fait consensus
quels que soient les partis politiques
alors comment faire une réforme
d'ampleur sur ce sujet y a t-il les
moyens pour pour la faire mais je le
président de la république a annoncé au
mois de novembre dernier qu'il allait
mettre en place un plan soins palliatifs
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
c'est une excellente idée c'est vrai que
les plans présidentielle ça marche
toujours on l'a vu avec le plan anti
cancer du président jacques chirac ou le
plan éphémère du président sarkozy si ce
plan dont on attend maintenant les
les modalités et mise en place ça ira
beaucoup plus vite
donc quand même moi j'attends avec
impatience ce plan de soins palliatifs
que le président de république a annoncé
merci beaucoup alain milon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions tout de suite on
prend donc la direction de la séance
pour les débats dessinateur alors dans
la discussion générale et bien la parole
est à madame la ministre marisol
touraine
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales messieurs les co-rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un sujet sensible qui nous
rassemble cet après midi quand la
crainte de la vie l'emportent sur la
crainte de la mort ce sont les mots de
victor hugo et ses maux trouvent un écho
chez tous ceux qui ont eu à affronter la
fin de vie difficile d'un proche ou qui
pensent ou qui au fond sont confrontés
par l'intermédiaire de personnes connues
de fait médiatique à ces situations en
arriver au point de préférer mourir pour
ne plus souffrir
c'est sans doute la plus terrible des
appréhensions la fin de vie est
évidemment un moment intime et pour
autant on ne peut la résumer à la sphère
privée
parce que nous savons bien le rapport à
la maladie à la mort résulte de notre
culture d'un ensemble de règles de code
qui évolue progressivement et depuis des
siècles jamais sans doute les évolutions
dont elle était aussi rapide sous la
pression d'inspirations diverses
d'ailleurs aspiration à la liberté à une
plus grande liberté en tout cas reconnu
aspiration à l'exercice de la
responsabilité à la reconnaissance de
l'autonomie
nous avons le devoir d' apaiser sans
jamais remettre en cause
l'aspiration à l'autonomie nous devons
poser
des limites mais ne pas ignorer la
souffrance parce que la modernité d'une
société se mesure pour beaucoup à son
rapport aux malades aux souffrants à sa
capacité à faire évoluer des règles qui
soit acceptée de tous et on ne peut le
nier notre rapport à la maladie notre
rapport à la mort a changé d'abord les
soins palliatifs se sont imposés dans le
débat mais ils ne sont pas accessibles à
tous dans les mêmes conditions nos
concitoyens ont des droits nouveaux
depuis quelques années et pourtant ils
ne les connaissent pas suffisamment les
progrès de la science de la médecine
nous permettent de vivre plus longtemps
ce qui est assurément une chance et dans
le même temps ces mêmes traitements
peuvent faire durer la maladie parfois
trop longtemps maintenir en vie dans des
conditions qui reste sujet à
interrogations à tel point que pour
certains la frontière entre la vie et la
mort s'estompe
aussi il y a donc une demande dans notre
pays de faire évoluer le cadre
législatif et c'est assurément une
exigence exigence morale pour certains
exigences politiques en tout cas au sens
fort du terme de la vie de la cité
les malades leurs familles les
associations les professionnels de santé
aussi le demande de nous saisir de ce
sujet délicat avec responsabilité est
d'apporter des réponses à des questions
qui parfois aujourd'hui reste dans le
vide
c'est pour répondre à cette attente que
le président de la république a pris
l'engagement de mieux accompagner la fin
de vie
dans le contexte d'une maladie incurable
d'une souffre d'une souffrance
insupportable
il fallait d'abord c'était le souhait du
président la république permettre à la
société de s'exprimer le plus
directement et le plus largement
possible
c'est ainsi qu'une mission a été confiée
au professeur sicard que le comité
consultatif
national d'éthique à mener des travaux
et qu'à travers ces débats les français
ont pu s'emparer de ce sujet et
s'exprimer aussi dans le cadre d'une
conférence citoyenne patients
professionnels de santé représentants
des grandes familles de pensée ou des
familles religieuses tous ont pu faire
valoir leur point de vue est ensuite
venu le moment d'élaborer un texte
le président de la république en a fixé
le cadre parvenir un consensus le plus
large possible pour proposer une étape
législative nouvelle
une mission a été confiée à deux députés
alain claeys et jean leonetti qui ont
rendu leurs travaux en décembre dernier
et rédiger une proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui même si elle
a été en partie modifiée lors de son
examen à l'assemblée nationale elle
marque des avancées importantes
d'abord le texte qui est proposée
renforce l'accès aux soins palliatifs
qui aujourd'hui est insuffisant depuis
dix ans les unités ou des unités de
soins palliatifs se sont développées en
france le nombre de lits a été multiplié
par vingt pourtant si les deux tiers des
français qui meurent de maladies
auraient besoin de soins palliatifs
une grande partie d'entre eux n'y a pas
accès ou alors trop tardivement
c'est une injustice en tout cas c'est
perçue comme telle injustice à la fois
sociale et territoriale et c'est ce qu'a
montré un rapport de la cour des comptes
de cette année même c'est pour cela que
avant même de réfléchir aux évolutions à
apporter aux conditions dans lesquelles
la fin de vie peut être aménagée il
apparaît nécessaire de proposer un
nouveau plan de développement des soins
palliatifs
il s'agit de
développer la culture palliative dans
notre pays en mettant en avant plusieurs
priorités d'abord garantir que ces soins
palliatifs pourront être développés ce
qui n'est pas suffisamment le cas
aujourd'hui dans les établissements pour
personnes âgées les ehpad partout sur le
territoire
ensuite il faut répondre à la demande
très forte très pressante de nos
concitoyens de pouvoir bénéficier ou de
pouvoir accéder à des soins palliatifs à
domicile alors que la majorité des
français ont le souhait souhaiterait
pouvoir mourir chez elle à domicile et
que l'absence de soins palliatifs ça
n'est pas la seule raison
les amènent souvent trop souvent à
mourir à l'hôpital
nous devons aussi permettre et proposer
une meilleure formation des personnels
soignants qui se disent eux-mêmes
ignorants des démarches à engager en
intégrant un enseignement spécifique
consacré à l'accompagnement des malades
dans toutes les formations sanitaires
il nous faut enfin proposer des
procédures communes aux professionnels
de santé pour accompagner la sortie
d'hôpital des patients qui ont besoin de
soins palliatifs et qu'ils rentrent chez
eux ou vont dans une maison de retraite
et c'est cette nécessité d'éviter toute
rupture qui doit faire l'objet d'un
référentiel commun la haute autorité de
santé il travaille un plan triennal est
en voie d'élaboration qui sera soumis
dès la semaine prochaine un comité de
pilotage composé des acteurs des soins
palliatifs et ce comité de peau de
pilotage éclairera complétera si
nécessaire les orientations que je
proposerai à cette occasion ensuite un
plan finalisé sera proposé enfin je
présenterai un plan finalisé pour
permettre au cours des trois années à
venir la montée en charge de cette offre
de soins palliatifs
mais au-delà ou deux
ont renforcé la possibilité donnée à nos
concitoyens de faire valoir leurs droits
les français le div
ils ne connaissent pas suffisamment
leurs droits près de la moitié d'entre
eux ignorent que la loi autorise d'ores
et déjà le patient a demandé l'arrêt des
traitements qui le maintiennent en vie
seuls deux et demi pour cent de nos
concitoyens 2,5 pour cent de nos
concitoyens ont rédigé des directives
anticipées alors que nous savons qu'elle
pourrait répondre à nombre de situations
difficiles la situation largement
médiatisée de vincent lambert qui n'est
pas en fin de vie il faut le préciser
rappelle la nécessité de tout faire pour
que puisse s'exprimer la volonté de
chacun les difficultés auxquelles est
confrontée où nous sommes confrontés le
corps médical les difficultés qui sont
liées à la situation de vincent lambert
viennent en partie du fait que
l'expression de sa volonté fait l'objet
d'interrogations et de débats et donc
nous devons renforcer clarifier le cadre
de l'expression personnelle de notre
volonté le texte dont nous allons
débattre propose donc de rendre des
directives anticipées contraignante et
d'en supprimer la durée de validité
c'est une avancée majeure aujourd'hui
les directives anticipées lorsqu'elles
existent le constituent que l'un des
éléments à prendre en compte dans la
décision médicale demain c'est bien la
volonté du patient qui sera déterminante
pour définir l'issue de la vie rester
maître de sa vie jusqu'au dernier moment
jusqu'au moment où on la quitte c'est
l'enjeu de dignité auquel le texte
cherche à répondre mais il s'agit aussi
de donner davantage d'informations sur
ce que sont ces directives information
du patient qui doit connaître son droit
pour pouvoir l'exercer informations de
l'équipe médicale
qui doit avoir connaissance le plus
rapidement et le plus clairement
possible d volonté du malade
les amendements qui ont été adoptées par
l'assemblée nationale renforce ce volet
du texte
concrètement un formulaire type de
directives anticipées sera élaboré sous
l'égide de la haute autorité de santé et
un registre national automatisé
permettra à chaque français de rédiger
une directive anticipée de la manière la
plus simple qui soit ces dispositifs
permettront de donner aux médecins une
visibilité rapide immédiate sur les
directives du malade dont ils ont la
charge
ils pourront évidemment facilement
consulter ce registre dont les données
seront confidentielles et dont il
s'agira évidemment là encore de garantir
la confidentialité
il nous revient de trouver les moyens
d'informer utilement nos concitoyens sur
ce droit nouveau
enfin la troisième orientation de ce
texte c'est de consacrer une plus grande
autonomie des personnes
l'encadrement de l'arrêt des traitements
permis par la loi d'avril 2005 a
constitué un progrès indéniable pour la
dignité des personnes
personne d'ailleurs ne le conteste mais
il nous faut aujourd'hui franchir une
étape supplémentaire pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que en l'état
actuel de notre droit
c'est aux seuls médecins que revient la
décision d'interrompre ou de ne pas ou
de ne pas interrompre les traitements
d'initiés ou de ne pas initier les
traitements si un dialogue a évidemment
lieu au sein des équipes soignantes des
médecins peuvent parfois être désemparée
face aux décisions qui leur revient de
prendre
et lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à ce
moment très précis d'interrompre ou pas
le traitement
dans le même temps et nous le voyons
quotidiennement
dans les débats publics trop de patients
trop de familles ont le sentiment de ne
pas être entendus et ont le sentiment
que leurs droits sont mal reconnus c'est
pour cela qu'il s'agit de renforcer le
droit des malades en fin de vie et
d'apporter aussi une sécurité à la fois
aux patients et aux soignants pour que
la diversité des situations et des
prises en charge sur le territoire
national soit réduite parce que l'on
s'aperçoit que selon l'interprétation
donnée de la loi selon les équipes
soignantes selon les lieux où l'on se
trouve sur le territoire
les réponses apportées à des situations
identiques ne sont pas les mêmes c'est
ce que propose ce texte qui précise les
modalités d'interruption des traitements
il clarifie la notion d'obstination
déraisonnable et propose d'instaurer un
droit à bénéficier d'une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au des faits
lorsque le pronostic vital est engagé à
court terme
à l'heure actuelle ce traitement relève
the lady de la seule appréciation
médical son application dépend donc
largement du territoire de
l'établissement ou du service il s'agira
désormais d'un droit concret reconnu à
tous et partout mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le sujet je le disais en
commençant est un sujet sensible celui
de la fin de vie et il nous concerne
tous individuellement collectivement par
delà nos croyances nos engagements nos
parcours nos points de vue nous avons
une grande mission collective qui est de
répondre aux attentes exprimées par nos
concitoyens
ce texte permettra de franchir une étape
considérable l'opposabilité des
directives anticipées
couplé à la reconnaissance de la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès inverse la logique
décision c'est le patient et non plus le
médecin qui a le premier le dernier mot
c'est lui qui devient le maître de son
destin
il s'agit de redonner jusqu'aux derniers
instants de la force à la volonté et à
la liberté de chaque personne ce sujet
et ne pouvons pas le nier fait appel à
la conscience de chacun je crois que
nous devons aborder ce débat en
conscience avec la conviction que nul ne
détient une vérité absolue et que chacun
doit pouvoir exprimer sa conviction
profonde sur vauban comme sur ceux de
l'assemblée nationale assurément et dans
le pays
certains considèrent que ce texte ne va
pas assez loin
d'autres estiment que toute évolution du
cadre juridique de la fin de vie est
inopportune on a entendu du côté de ceux
qui estiment qu'il faudrait aller plus
loin des démarches différentes être
proposé il n'y a pas là encore de
consensus absolu sur la question savoir
qu'elle serait l'étape supplémentaire à
franchir
le gouvernement souhaite que le débat
s'engage de manière sereine
il n'appartient à personne de porter un
jugement sur les convictions des uns des
autres qui sont tout aussi respectable
il s'agit aujourd'hui de proposer un
texte qui rassemble largement et qui
constitue un point d'équilibré dans la
société c'est la volonté du président de
la république
le président a fixé un cap clair
franchir et permettent de franchir une
étape de liberté pour les malades et le
faire dans le rassemblement
le sénat est sans doute le lieu le plus
à même de répondre à cette double
exigence et d'entendre cet appel parce
que l'engagement historique des
sénatrices des sénateurs sur ce sujet
montre bien que des rassemblements
peuvent s'opérer par delà les clivages
partisans
parce que vous avez la volonté d'être
attentif à l'aspiration à la dignité des
personnes en fin de vie
je ne doute pas que nos débats seront
des débats importants utile éclairant
pour notre société je ne doute pas non
plus que des points de vue différents
s'exprimeront et que des aspirations
différentes s'exerceront et je ne vous
apprendrai rien en vous disant que ça
même de l'exécutif
il y a eu des points de vue différents
qui se sont exprimés et la question qui
au fond a permis de rassembler c'est de
se demander comment aujourd'hui dans la
situation dans laquelle se trouve la
société française on peut faire
progresser le débat répondre à
l'exigence de liberté d'autonomie et de
dignité sans heurter merci à vous merci
madame la ministre à la parole et à
notre collègue monsieur gérard dériot co
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi soumise à notre
examen s'inscrit dans des débats déjà
anciens auxquels certains d'entre nous
ont eu l'occasion de participer et qui
n'ont rien perdu de leur actualité
l'annoncé par le président de la
république en décembre dernier d'un
nouveau plan triennal de développement
des soins palliatifs marque d'ailleurs
le besoin d'une meilleure prise en
charge des personnes malades dans notre
pays et plus particulièrement des
personnes en fin de vie
plusieurs lois successives ont consacré
des principes clairs et protecteur
d'abord l'accès de tous aux soins
palliatifs avec la loi du 9 juin 9 juin
le consentement libre et éclairé des
malades aux soins avec la loi du 4 mars
2002 troisièmement la possibilité de
l'arrêt des traitements en fin de vie
avec la loi dite leonetti du 22 avril
2005 relative aux droits des malades et
à la fin de vie or nous le savons tous
la réalité malgré d'incontestables
progrès ne correspond pas à la volonté
du législateur
la persistance du mal mourir dans notre
pays n'a cessé de peser sur les
conditions du débat public depuis plus
de 15 ans l'inégalité de l'accès aux
soins palliatifs est forte en
particulier selon les territoires
comme l'a récemment rappelé la cour des
comptes
je souhaite cependant d'emblée insisté
sur un point
prévoir de nouvelles contraintes
législatives pour le déploiement des
soins palliatifs n'ajoute rien à la loi
de 1999 et n'aura pas plus d'effet car
le véritable enjeu est bien celui des
moyens madame la ministre vous avez la
lourde charge d'une situation difficile
dans le contexte budgétaire que chacun
connaît mais c'est ce dont vous avez ri
et rites et ses terres de la situation
du développement des soins palliatifs
dans notre pays qui développement qui
est très largement insuffisant où l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est cependant
sur vous que repose l'obligation pour
l'état de garantir à chacun l'accès
effectif aux soins palliatifs
je souhaite également réaffirmé que la
loi dite leonetti est une bonne loi
son adoption rapide en 2005 a donné une
base à la lutte contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique
cette vase et des armes désormais
consacrée par la jurisprudence
européenne est de plus en plus intégrés
aux pratiques
il ne faut pas à l'occasion du débat sur
cette proposition de loi defferre les
principes en place depuis 10
et qui chaque jour permettent aux
personnes malades en fin de vie et à
leur entourage de trouver des solutions
conformes à leur dignité et à la
déontologie des soignants même si comme
chacun le constate également
et bien malheureusement cette loi n'est
pas assez connu dans le corps médical
d'une part mais deuxièmement aussi
auprès de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
la proposition de loi de nos collègues
députés alain claeys et jean leonetti
est critiqué parce qu'ils craignent que
les évolutions successives du droit ne
pousse les personnes en fin de vie a
considéré que leur existence est une
charge pour les autres mais aussi par
ceux pour qui la vie relève du sacré
elle n'est pas moins critiqué par ceux
qui réclament le droit à une assistance
médicalisée pour mourir ou au suicide
assisté
la commission des affaires sociales
partage pour sa part l'objectif des
auteurs qui est de compléter sans
rupture la législation en vigueur depuis
plus de 15 ans il n'y a à nos yeux dans
ce texte
aucune ouverture vers l'assistance
médicalisée pour mourir ou vers le
suicide assisté
la commission a estimé que la
proposition de loi propose un juste
équilibre entre la volonté du patient et
le savoir médical entre l'obligation de
préserver la vie humaine et les souhaits
de chacun
quant aux conditions de sa fin de vie
afin de préciser certaines dispositions
du texte est de limiter le caractère
automatique des décisions concernant la
fin de vie elle a néanmoins adopté deux
amendements sur les articles 1er à 14
michel amiel mon co rapporteurs vous
présentera les principales modifications
adoptées je m'en tiendrais pour ma part
aux articles 8 et 9 relatifs
respectivement aux directives anticipées
et à la personne de confiance
l'article 8 rend opposable aux médecins
les directives anticipées
cette évolution
est notable car à l'heure actuelle elles
deviennent caduques
au bout de trois ans si elles ne sont
pas renouvelés et n'ont de valeur qu'à
indicative le renforcement du statut des
directives anticipées est attendue même
si seuls 2% de la population française
en a rédigé il apparaît de nature à
rééquilibrer la relation entre les
droits des malades et le savoir médical
la commission a cependant souhaité
préciser les conditions dans lesquelles
le médecin n'est pas tenu de respecter
les directives anticipées
les auteurs de la proposition de loi
avait en effet défini deux cas dans
lesquels le médecin aurait la
possibilité de ne pas les appliquer
premièrement le le premier ne fait pas
débat il s'agit de l'urgence vitale
par exemple la réanimation des personnes
accidentées ou ayant fait une tentative
de suicide
le second était celui du caractère
manifestement inappropriées des
directives
la commission a modifié cette formule
qu'elle n'a pas jugé pleinement
satisfaisante car elle pouvait aboutir
en pratique a privé des faits le
caractère opposable des directives
la commission a également souhaité
étendre le recours à la procédure
collégiale et renforcer la place de la
personne de confiance à l'heure actuelle
cette procédure collégiale relève en
effet du code de déontologie médicale
qui a valeur réglementaire
il convient de préciser dans la loi les
conditions minimales de son organisation
et de prévoir en particulier
l'association de la personne de
confiance ou à défaut de la famille ou
des proches qui le souhaitent à
l'article 9 qui concernent la personne
de confiance la commission a jugé utile
d'inscrire l'obligation pour celle-ci de
cosigner sa désignation
effectivement il s'agit d'éviter les cas
où une personne découvre qu'elle a été
désigné sans jamais avoir accepté de
remplir cette mission
il nous semblait
nous a semblé que c'était le meilleur
moyen de pouvoir mettre les choses à
plat avant que michel amiel ne prenne la
parole je souhaitais rappelé que ce
texte ce texte répond aux préoccupations
de nos concitoyens qu'ils offrent des
garanties suffisantes pour les personnes
les plus vulnérables sans remettre en
cause les équilibres auxquels nous
sommes parvenus en 2005 et c'est
pourquoi maintenant je vais laisser la
parole à michel amiel pour la suite
merci merci monsieur bériault
effectivement la parole étant notre
collègue monsieur michel amiel co
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales bonjour michel monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues gérard dériot l'a bien montré
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui ne concerne pas les
personnes qui veulent mourir mais celles
qui vont mourir son objet principal est
d'améliorer la prise en compte des
souffrances réfractaires en fin de vie
et quand je dis souffrance je ne dis pas
seulement douleur physique
les chiffres ne manquent pas pour
illustrer l'écart entre la mort souhaité
apaiser et à domicile et les conditions
de la mort de la majorité des français
en ehpad à l'hôpital voir aux urgences
cette situation résulte d'un manque de
moyens bien sûr mais peut-être aussi et
surtout de l'absence d'une véritable
culture palliative en france
oui pour reprendre l'expression du
professeur 6/4 on meurt mal en france
outre le peu de temps consacré aux soins
palliatifs dans la formation des
professionnels de santé
l'intervention des soins palliatifs
restent encore trop souvent associée à
un échec des soins curatifs et donc
finalement du corps médical lui même
soins palliatifs traitement curatif
doivent s'intégrer dans une même logique
de prise en charge
nous sommes bien face à un embarras
d'années de sin acquis la société a
confié le soin de s'occuper de la mort
or le temps de l'accompagnement ne peut
être exclusivement celui de la médecine
j'en viens au texte soumis à l'examen de
notre assemblée
la commission des affaires sociales a
jugé nécessaire d'apporter plusieurs
modifications à la proposition de loi
pour précisiez ou clarifier certaines
dispositions
il s'est agi de limiter le caractère
automatique des décisions qui concernent
la fin de vie et d'accroître ainsi la
sécurité juridique des dispositifs ainsi
à l'article 2 qui concerne l'obstination
déraisonnable
l'application stricte des dispositions
initialement prévu ont récusé conséquent
ce qui à notre sens ne correspondent pas
aux objectifs poursuivis
nous avons supprimé le caractère
automatique de l'arrêt des traitements
pour donner la primauté à la volonté du
patient
la commission a également défini les
obligations minimales qui s'attache à la
mise en oeuvre de la procédure
collégiale
celle ci suppose désormais la réunion de
l'équipe soignante mais aussi
l'association de la personne de
confiance ou à défaut de la famille ou
des proches
cette procédure est organisée à
l'initiative du médecin pour les
décisions d'arrêt ou de limitation des
traitements de recours à la sédation
profonde et continue et d'application
des directives anticipées
la commission a supprimé la mention de
l'hydratation et de l'alimentation
artificielle afin de s'en tenir à la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état à
l'article 3
la proposition de loi prévoit un cadre
spécifique et encadrée pour une pratique
qui existe déjà en soins palliatifs
la sédation profonde et continue une
personne en fin de vie dans le pronostic
vital est engagé à court terme qui est
atteint d'une souffrance réfractaires et
qui demande à ne plus souffrir
et dans ce cadre souhaite l'arrêt de
l'ensemble des traitements y compris de
maintien artificiel a envie aura le
droit d'obtenir une sédation profonde et
continue
associé à une analgésie jusqu'à son
décès pour reprendre l'expression du
professeur régis aubry
le malade n'est pas obligé d'assister au
drame tragique de sa mort c'est la
volonté de la personne qui prime c'est
elle qui formulent la demande si elle ne
souhaite pas ou n'accepte pas l'arrêt
des traitements artificielle de maintien
en vie le texte arty le texte actuel
n'ouvrent pas droit à la sédation
profonde et continue
l'arrêt des traitements n'est pas
imposée par le médecin il est choisi par
la personne malade en toute conscience
je rappelle que le droit pour une
personne malade de refuser les soins
quel qu'il soit fait partie intégrante
de notre droit depuis la loi de 2002
la commission a supprimé la mention de
prolongation inutile de la vie jugé
source d'ambiguïté
elle a précisé que dans le cas où une
personne souhaite arrêter tout
traitement engageant ainsi son pronostic
vital à court terme
la sédation profonde et continue n'est
mise en oeuvre qu'en cas de souffrance
réfractaires en cas de souffrance
réfractaires
cette nouvelle rédaction vise à écarter
toute dérive vers le suicide assisté
pour mesurer objectivement les
améliorations apportées par le texte
il faut cependant garder à l'esprit que
la loi ne permet pas d'apporter de
réponse évidente à toutes les situations
et qu'elle n'a pas vocation à le faire
je pense notamment au cas dans lesquels
une personne en d'état d'exprimer sa
volonté n'a pas rédigé de directives
anticipées ni désigné de personnes de
confiance et qu'il n'y a pas de
consensus au sein de la famille sur
l'arrêt des traitements
ce qui nous renvoie à une caressant
largement médiatisés dans ces situations
dramatiques la décision d'arrêter le
traitement ne pourra être prise que par
le médecin s'ils estiment que la
prolongation des traitements relèverait
de l'obstination des réseaux
abl ou bien alors par le juge en tout
état de cause il revient au gouvernement
de se saisir de l'occasion offerte par
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
pour mener un véritable travail de
pédagogie auprès de nos concitoyens ce
qui peut être n'avait pas suffisamment
été fait après la loi de 2005
le texte issu des travaux de la
commission des affaires sociales ne
marque pas de désaccord avec la
proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale
il constitue une avancée réelle pour les
patients dont l'autonomie juridique sera
renforcée nous en partageons l'esprit
car il propose un juste équilibre entre
la volonté des patients et le pouvoir du
corps médical entre l'obligation de
préserver la vie humaine et celle de
permettre à chacun de décider des
conditions dans lesquelles ils
souhaitent qu'elles s'éteignent les
visions opposées mais également
respectable qui vont s'exprimer lors de
nos débats nous renforcent dans cette
conviction la commission des affaires
sociales vous demande donc d'adopter
cette proposition de loi
sous réserve des amendements de
précisions qu'elle vous soumettra je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue monsieur
françois piles et rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des lois le président
madame la ministre je présentais comme
si aux affaires sociales
ce les rapporteurs mesdames messieurs
mes chers collègues aux limites de la
souffrance au bout de la maladie
la vie est-elle un privilège ou une
fatalité
la proposition de loi objet de notre
débat traite d'un sujet difficile et
sensible qui engage à la fois des
considérations médicales et juridiques
des questionnements éthiques et
philosophiques et surtout des
souffrances humaines la fin de vie les
douleurs qui l'accompagnent l'ultime
choix laissé aux patients et le rôle de
la médecine aux feuilles de la mort
appelle donc une réflexion prudente et
empreinte d'humilité
madame le ministre ait omis chers
collègues avait présenté la proposition
de loi
deux principes cardinaux de la
législation française en encadré et
déterminer la position de la commission
des lois la prohibition absolue que la
mort soit donnée activement et
intentionnellement et le respect dans ce
cadre de la volonté de la personne en
prévoyant de consacrer dans certains cas
un droit pour le patient bénéficier
d'une sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'à son décès la proposition de loi
ne crée pas une nouvelle pratique
médicale en ultime soins d'ores et déjà
les équipes soignantes et recours dans
un souci d'humanité pour éviter aux
patients les souffrances de sa maladie
ou de saône agonie en revanche élevée
cette possibilité au rang d'un droit
garantirait aux patients de pouvoir
réclamer le bénéfice de cette sédation
contre un médecin qui le lui refuserait
car fort peu probable au regard des
exigences de la déontologie médicale ou
de pouvoir en réclamer le bénéfice
contre l'établissement hospitalier où
les services qui le soigne ce qui est
plus plausible compte tenu du retard de
notre pays dans le développement des
soins palliatifs mais des situations
différentes change le sens qui peut être
donnée
la consécration de ce droit la sédation
le conseil d'état a énoncé une
préoccupation qui n'a cessé d'être à
l'esprit de la commission des lois
je cite la sédation profonde ne peut en
aucun cas être un substitut aux soins
palliatifs une solution de facilité qui
viendraient en quelque sorte pallier
leur absence dans le texte adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales le
recours à la sédation profonde et permis
lorsque le patient en fin de vie atteint
d'une maladie grave et incurable éprouve
une souffrance réfractaires à tout
traitement comprenant la gamme entière
des soins palliatifs et lorsque le
patient hors d'état d'exprimer sa
volonté subi un acharnement
thérapeutique une décision d'arrêt du
traitement le maintenant en vie est
prise au titre du refus de l'obstination
déraisonnable
la commission des lois a marqué son
plein accord avec la proche ainsi retenu
par la commission des affaires sociales
mais il lui est apparu qu'un lien
systématique entre la sédation profonde
et continue elle arrête tous les
traitements poser question parce qu'ils
seraient principalement contradictoires
de reconnaître un nouveau droit aux
patients tout en limitant la liberté
dans l'exercice de ce droit est parce
que lié indissolublement sédation
profonde et arrêt des traitements vitaux
rend plus indistinctes la frontière
entre la mort causée par la maladie et
une mort causée par autre chose que
cette maladie la commission des lois
soit redonné toute force à la volonté du
patient au seuil de celle ci nous en
débattrons lors des échanges concernant
un un moment que je présenterai sur ce
point au nom de la commission des lois
le même souci de respecter le choix
personnel a conduit votre commission des
lois a écarté le recours à la procédure
collégiale
lorsque le refus de traitement titre de
l'obstination déraisonnable est exprimée
clairement et consciemment par le
patient lui-même privilégier la volonté
de la personne en fin de vie revient à
tout mettre en oeuvre pour s'assurer de
son contenu la proposition de loi fin
choix faire des directives anticipées
une preuve absolue de la volonté du
patient
les auteurs du dax ont ainsi choisi de
renforcer substantiellement la force des
directives anticipées en supprimant leur
durée de validité de trois ans et en
prévoyant qu elle s'imposerait aux
médecins
le texte établit une hiérarchie entre
les différents éléments de preuve en
présence les différents et directives
anticipées l'emporterait sur tout autre
témoignage à défaut de directives c'est
le témoignage de la personne de
confiance qui ferait foi en dernier lieu
serait plan compte les éléments
recueillis par la famille ou les proches
port pour parfaire notre recherche de la
réalité de la volonté du patient
il est nécessaire de bien dissocier deux
questions dans notre réflexion
la première concerne la validité des
directives anticipées au regard des
souhaits les plus récents exprimée par
le patient avant qu'il ne sombre et dans
la conscience ce indépendamment du
contenu de ces directives
la seconde concerne l'effet contraignant
des directives à l'égard des médecins
d'alors que le contenu n'est pas adaptée
à la situation médicale du patient
il existe en effet un risque grave
affaire des directives anticipées la
preuve irréfragable de la volonté du
malade
certes les directives constitue
l'élément le plus fiable pour déterminer
la volonté d'un patient en état
d'inconscience
mais il est dangereux de leur attribuer
un caractère trop absolue aux risques
qu'elle se retourne contre le patient
lui-même comme l'a souligné monsieur
jean-marc le sauvé vice-président du
conseil d'état
lors de son intervention au colloque
organisé par le sénat sur la fin de vie
en janvier dernier je le cite lorsque le
patient est dans un état d'inconscience
ces directives anticipées exprime une
présomption de volonté elles sont une
approximation certes très forte de ce
qu'aurait été sa volonté consciente mais
cette présomption ne serait être
irréfragable
elle doit pouvoir être écartée lorsqu un
faisceau d'indicés probants et
circonstanciée démontre qu'elle ne
correspond plus à la volonté du patient
dès lors les directives anticipées
doivent pouvoir être révoqué par tous
moyens et le médecin doit pouvoir
s'assurer de leur vallée vic pour
améliorer autant que faire se peut la
mise à jour des directives anticipées ou
sera proposé que le décret en conseil
d'état qui fixe notamment les conditions
de conservation de ces directives
prévoient également un rappel régulier
de l'existence de celle ci dans du
registre national concernant la personne
de confiance la rédaction actuelle du
texte
si ce que sa parole prévaudrait sur tout
autre élément permettant d'établir la
volonté du patient à l'exclusion des
directives anticipées
sans doute est il sur ce point
préférable de revenir au texte de
l'assemblée nationale qui ne l'a fait
prévaloir que sur les autres témoignages
je réserve de quelques autres
propositions d'amendements qui viendront
discussion tout à leur apporter plus
directement juridique ou rédactionnelle
issus les débats de la commission des
lois
j'ai tenté d'exprimer synthétiquement
les priorités que celle ci dans l'examen
de ce texte
vous avez compris qu'elles veulent
assurer une totale protection des
décisions du patient or celle conduisant
à une mort données active avant d'en
débattre on peut occulter le malaise
ressenti face à une situation
témoignant d'un exemple éclatant de
notre propre puissance pas une et pas un
d'entre nous ne niera sérieusement quand
son for intérieur il sait qu'il accepte
de légiférer pour corriger l'étendue de
droit restait quasiment à l'étape
proclamation et pourtant ses droits en
avril 2005 avait été instaurée au sénat
par un vote conforme en première lecture
d'un texte voté à l'unanimité de
l'assemblée nationale et ces droits sont
cités on vieillit saluer si l'on sait de
quoi on parle
quand on évoque la notion de soins
palliatifs on ne change pas un mot à la
résolution du conseil de l'europe du 29
janvier 2009 qui je signe considère les
soins palliatifs comme un élément
essentiel des soins de santé appropriés
fondée sur une conception humanitaire de
la dignité humaine sur l'autonomie sur
les droits de l'homme du citoyen et du
patient ainsi que sur une conception
généralement admise de la solidarité et
de la cohésion sociale et le français de
on parle on dénonce avec le comité
consultatif national d'éthique dans son
rapport publié le 21 octobre 2014 jeu si
le scandale que constitue depuis 15 ans
le non accès aux droits reconnus par la
loi
la situation d'abandon d'une immense
majorité de personnes en fin de vie et
l'a20 et la fin de vie insupportables
d'une très grande majorité de nos
concitoyens
madame laure copel responsable d'un
service de soins palliatifs dont les
propos sont relatés dans le monde de ce
mercredi une place devant notre
responsabilité
je la cite le danger est extrême de
n'avoir que l'association a apporté
comme réponse à une absence de soins de
qualité dans ces circonstances nous
pouvons certainement nous accorder pour
légiférer mais à la condition expresse
fermement et fortement rappelé que nous
ne transigerons pas sur le droit pour
tous d'accéder à une médecine palliative
dans une unique et indivisible culture
du soin